and I want to welcome to this video
playing Godzilla Godzilla I'm really
really high rating that writes an older
counter okay so let's see my ratty has
served me quite well let's see how
good's Eli's going to do it with the a
pawn okay
tending to go before
[Music]
try to play before you yeah this is an
interesting way of playing it now I can
take and this is a somewhat
unconventional structure of tonight x
take and now yeah 93 is a bit annoying
so I'm going to cover this you can take
on b3 now f6 okay
[Music]
no reason not to take it I think
let's see how he gets it back
so I wonder if I should go I think I
should go III simply cover the before
square and then try to put pressure on
the beep on don't know what he's doing
here a name Bishop d7 try to get this
back on I mean if he doesn't do
something apply light c-4 would be one
and just just pressurize him down
and now d 5 is is unprotected so I can
actually take on e5 it would be possible
I don't see why why not
it's a very strange game maybe go see I
got some what do those things do in the
movies I get nuclear shocks or whatever
something then they get hunted maybe you
got too close to some real nuclear
reactor so okay so okay I'll take here
it takes 25 i take p 6 and then what
yeah sure but I have some things going
on here what to do Queen B 5 simply and
look the seven check
this is also I think simple a good move
you know after the capture rules yeah it
really it falls apart complete them yeah
that that that went wrong in the opening
for black pretty um pretty bad name yeah
I think you should just take on b3 I
mean the computer likes white there as
well yeah i do i do i do too would
probably still have to do it i mean he
you're just a pawn down with black and
you got tons of weaknesses only know
that's more or less open now and 95
wasn't exactly difficult Queen B file is
also strong out but okay I wasn't
completely sure just 94 year okay yeah
but it's also enough that's the line
that I saw this this and night hanks and
96 that wins the house and I'm already
two bonds up so that's just huge
material loss and I had more time and so
on yeah okay guys thanks for watching